we can speak now to the deputy secretary
general of the national education union
neve sweeney thank you so much for being
on the programme
do you feel like a teacher strike is
inevitable
i think it's more likely than it's been
in my 20 years of working in the
profession uh if you know even before
the pandemic teachers were working more
unpaid over time than any other
profession and when early career
teachers calculate their hourly pay
they're often being paid under the
living wage as a graduate profession the
pay simply hasn't kept up with with
other uh graduate professions and
teachers are saying to us
that they are finding it difficult to
get to the end of the month their
heating bills and their fuel bills mean
that they are struggling to survive
uh yeah i mean look look i think don't
think anyone would say that times are
easy particularly of course for people
who've had you know years of
pay restraint
i'm just interested to know exactly what
you're calling for so you say you want
an inflation plus pay rise inflation of
course is currently at 9.1 percent
what is the pay rise that you want to
see
well at the moment we think that the
strv is likely to recommend to the
secretary of state about a three three
percent pay increase now
with cpi or rpi that means an actual pay
cut for our members of between six and
eight percent and
of austerity and pay restraint and last
year's pay freeze so the average teacher
will have lost between 70 and 17 and 20
in real terms of their wages so if they
don't offer something that is more than
at least cpi inflation the majority of
teachers will be facing another year of
a pay cut
so let's just be really really clear
then on what you're calling for uh
inflation is currently at 9.1 percent so
so what it just spell out for us and
what is it that you want to see
we've said to nadeem sahabi today that
he needs to
very seriously consider an above
inflation pay rise for teachers across
the board and it needs to be fully
funded so we need to make sure that
schools are able to pay this because
what we're seeing is a teacher
recruitment and retention crisis one in
four teachers leaves the profession
within two years and one in three
teachers leaves within five and that
means that children and young people are
less likely
you want to see pay rise with over 9.1
that's correct is it we have to make
sure that teachers aren't having another
year of a pay cut and that's what
they've been suffering for the last 10
years plus the pay freeze that was
issued last year to all of you what
exactly are you calling for
so we we we have said that we're calling
for an above
above inflation pay pay fully funded pay
rise for all teachers and all education
workers we mustn't forget that support
staff uh you know support staff wages
have not kept up with those of retail or
hospitality and support staff members in
our schools work with some of our most
vulnerable children and those with
special educational need and disability
if the government doesn't address
teacher pay then it is going to face an
even bigger workforce crisis than it is
in at the moment and what we are seeing
is children in secondary school having
three or four maths teachers within a
year i've got a friend who's a physics
teacher who started after easter and
every time he comes to the end of a
lesson the children say to him sir are
you coming back next week children need
a qualified experienced teacher who is
committed to the profession that isn't
worried about whether they can pay their
mortgage that doesn't you know isn't
worried about whether they can uh fill
their car with petrol at the end of the
month and isn't facing two thousand
pound hike in their own child care fees
you know we're a profession of 76 women
who have suffered through austerity and
have suffered through the through the
pandemic there's a pay gap in a pension
gap and children and families and
schools deserve better okay um so pretty
clear then that you're going to be
balancing a fraction you want to see an
above inflation payroll say reading
between the lines of what you said
that's effectively double figures above
9.1 percent
so my other question is you know
children have lost so much education
time already because of the pandemic and
we know that it's the most deprived
children who've suffered because of that
you know according to the southern trust
social mobility fell by 12
thanks to the lost learning uh during
doing the pandemic
how comfortable are you that if teachers
do go on strike that's going to be more
lost hours for children in the classroom
and more disruption particularly you
know for those underprivileged children
teachers are acutely aware of the impact
that them taking strike action would
have on children that's why they would
never take it lightly and that's why you
know it's taken this crisis for for them
to be considering it but i've spoken to
more teachers this week who have said
that they would for the first time in
their career consider taking strike
action because they recognize that it's
not just about the pay in their pockets
it's about recruiting graduate teachers
into the profession and keeping teachers
in the profession so that children have
a well-qualified experienced teacher
teaching teaching them
we've seen you're right the children who
are most deprived you know it's often
the fact that they are coming from uh
families that the educational
disadvantage is already in place before
they reach school so if the government
is really
really you know true to its word about
leveling up it will invest in early
years education and invest in fully
funded pay increase that keeps teachers
in the classroom
okay um i've spoken to mitt lynch of the
rmt at the weekend who said that they're
effectively prepared to keep striking
until
they get what they are asking for when
it comes to pay
i just wonder if that's the same for
teachers how long could the strikes last
for
well we haven't had a pay offer from the
employer yet so we are hoping that the
department of education that is in tsar
we would read our letter today we'll
hear the news stories and all the
interviews of teachers that i've heard
on the news and regulations how long the
question is sorry to just to try and you
know
re get back to the question but the
question is how long could the strikes
last for
well we haven't even balloted yet sophie
so that's why we're putting this warning
out this is the strength of the feeling
and the crisis of the cost of living
that we are in right now we have said
that we we are committed from our
conference in uh easter to run an
indicative ballot in the autumn term and
we will be recommending to our members
that they vote yes for strike action
that's a warning stand i understand that
we're early in the process but i know
that
i know that you know parents will be
i know that parents will be like really
concerned about the idea of uh staff
going on strike even though of course
many i guess would understand the desire
for better pay you know were we talking
days are we talking weeks are we talking
months or do we just not know
that will be down to our members and
what they decide they are willing and
prepared to do
but i tell you what parents are also
concerned about parents are concerned
that teacher vacancies are up by 14
teachers are parents are concerned that
their children are their class sizes are
rising because classes are having to be
merged because teacher vacancies aren't
being filled and parents are concerned
that their children are being taught by
non-subject specialists we're finding it
more difficult to recruit i.t teachers
teachers that need to develop curriculum
that's vital for our economy and vital
for young people entering into the
workforce and the next phases phases of
their educational career that's what
teachers our parents are are extremely
worried about and nadim zahawi needs to
hear that call and needs to ensure that
teacher pay maintains its its balance
with other graduate professions and that
we are getting the right number of
teachers to come into the profession and
keeping teachers once they get there